previously on Brothers resisters brother
I'm just going away for another trip and
I've decided not to upload during this
time so I'll see you in seven in Silla
continues
my subscribers like Streisand damn look
who has returned for too long he was
missing for too long he let his people
suffer I'm back
no no go away the long wait is finally
over I am back let's see how the bros
managed to survive without me let's see
how they reacted to me being gone seven
days without cancer
pewds 2013
that's just one comment hey remember
that one time Pierce was fight what is
this
you're supposed to be upset why am I
here what's the point what why did I
come back why I don't yeah the little
[ __ ] of YouTube is gone for a god damn
it so he literally just left YouTube
I mean I might as well no one seems to
care no one cares it's late this is kind
of a copy of kc9 set because KZ nice
side took a break and I took a break I
am copying him
you must be [ __ ] that I can say
[ __ ] now my channel is edgy now see
nothing happened
parents I wish you had a great trip and
put some work to your hair that's it
that's it that's genius how could I have
been so blind
of course colored hair clickbait come
psych okay yeah I didn't really dye my
hair this is clickbait
that's how I'll win them back
for [ __ ] sake